[Music]
dave rubin is a talk show host comedian
and TV personality as many of you know
the host of the pop of the youtube talk
show the rubin report dave regularly
addresses big ideas such as free speech
political correctness and religion among
many other high-profile guests on the
show david interviewed sam harris ayaan
Hirsi Ali and Larry elder and we also
have yarn Brook here tonight you're on
Brook is the chairman of the board of
Iran Institute renowned best-selling
author and hosted the nationally
syndicated Iran Brook show which
broadcasts live on blog talk radio and
YouTube Brook is also an internationally
sought speaker whose talks from
capitalism inequality Iran in her
philosophy which you all know to be
objectivism Brook was born and raised in
Israel served as a first sergeant in the
Israeli military intelligence and earned
a Bachelors of Science and civil
engineering from the Technion in Israel
Institute of Technology and Haifa Israel
he moved to the United States and
received his MBA and PhD in finance from
the University of Austin Texas the I'm
Rand Institute fosters a growing
awareness understanding and acceptance
of an Rand's philosophy objectivism in
order to create a culture whose guiding
principles a reason rational
self-interest individualism and less a
fair capitalism student programs are a
major focus of the Institute and include
annual essay contests that award nearly
a hundred thousand dollars in prizes
student conferences student clubs
support seasonal internships and campus
events so if you are interested in that
you can visit Iran org and then one more
thing we wanted to give a big thanks to
our amazing event photographer Albert
Aaron of of Starfall productions he's
available for graduation pictures videos
anything of that sort so at the end of
the event if you'd like to speak to him
right back there Thank You Anthony
president of young Americans for liberty
[Applause]
and I also want to thank Christina who's
president turning-point also campus
coordinator Alex from the Iran from the
hynerian Institute I don't know where
Alex is
but without these great minds in these
great institutions we wouldn't be able
to put this event on so you guys know he
won't came to see no further ado Dave
and you're on alright thank you guys
you probably heard our mics this is just
for the for the feed so we're gonna try
to talk as loudly as possible
first off I'm very excited to be here I
just had my first-ever police escort to
a bathroom so I guess that means I've
met it you live now now you've live now
I've lived I mean there are police out
there I usually only do these events
either with 20 police officers or a
former IDF soldier so we've got does not
know Krav Maga you do not know problem
we're in a lot of trouble all right well
thank you guys for for coming out we're
gonna talk about ideas and we're gonna
talk about free speech we're gonna talk
about the role of government first off
we are putting this on my youtube
channel so can you crazy conservatives
Republicans Objectivists whatever you
consider yourselves can you make some
noise for the people watching
[Applause]
all right very well I'm actually shy I
mean I recognize a lot of you guys from
some of the the events through a RI and
and turning point that I've done lately
so it's just amazing to me that for as
as crappie as everything seems on
college campus these days you guys are
out here to talk about ideas Your Honor
I had about an hour in the car to do
this I think we've already given this
the talk to each other we're really open
right now we're willing to kind of take
this in any direction we're gonna try to
push and pull on each other a little bit
but we don't really have an agenda here
but I think originally this was set up
to be about about limited government
which is one of your big things I'll let
you kick it off and then we'll see but
we want you guys to interact we're gonna
do about 45 minutes of us talking and
then we're gonna do questions totally
uncensored from you guys so you're on
take it away
sure and and I'm gonna swivel a little
bit because you all over the place so
yeah the role of government so you know
we were talking in the car coming in
here and one of the interviews that dave
has done recently with Steven Pinker and
I don't know if you've read his latest
book enlightenment now let me just
endorse it right now you know the things
I disagree in the book but the book is
phenomenal and everybody everybody in
the planet should be reading this book
he's endorsing a big lefty by them yeah
big lefty right and one of the things
that pink identifies easy he goes
through a whole series of chapters we
tells us how good life is right now on
planet earth it's never been better
and he's absolutely right life
expectancy poverty rates a hunger all of
these things we're in a better situation
today than we've ever been before and he
identifies the cause of that and the
cause he says is basically human
ingenuity ideas the application of human
reason in solving problems now how is
this related to the role of government
because you ask yourself what kind of
environment allows for the thriving of
human reason what kind of environment
allows
for ideas not just to be thought of but
then implemented in reality and brought
into existence and what you realize
quickly it in if you study the history
this is exactly what happened is that
for ideas for people to come up with
ideas for people then to implement ideas
to make them a reality they need to be
free they need to be free you can't have
it when the Catholic Church is telling
you I don't know the Sun goes around the
earth it doesn't work the other way
around you you can't have it when some
autocrat tells you what to think or what
to do what business you can open or what
business you can't open you need to be
free free to think sometimes ridiculous
ideas that fail but then you fail that's
okay
but for the successful ideas to work
people have to have the freedom to try
them and to go out and do them and then
so freedom of what right because freedom
is a would everybody loves right
nobody's against freedom but freedom
from what well freedom means freedom
from coercion freedom for force freedom
from Authority and if you think about
what that means it really is the concept
that the founding fathers described as
individual rights wights really other
recognition that each individual is
should be free free from coercion free
to live their life as they see fit free
to think and to speak and to act as they
see fit as long as they're not harming
other people they have the right to
pursue the rational values necessary for
their own existence and they like and
therefore what the only role of
governor's I see it is to make that
freedom a reality and to make that
freedom reality what we need is to it's
the extract force when we get together
to make sure that you guys you know this
is why we have the police here right
don't attack me because of what I'm
saying right that's it
so we need freedom from force so they're
all the government is basically that
it's to guarantee that we can say what
we want to say do what we want to do and
otherwise leave us alone so police and
military and the judiciary and that kind
of environment is what fosters the kind
of creativity that has made
and and the the the production that has
made this world such an amazing world so
yeah it's it's simple so I love that one
of the things he said there was freedom
to think because you guys are in college
this is where you're supposed to learn
how to think and unfortunately what's
happening obviously on most college
campuses these days is that thinking is
sort of becoming an outlier in in what's
going on so it's interesting he
references your own references Steven
Pinker's book steven pinker again as I
said he's a lefty I think he would
probably say he's a progressive who
would disagree with you on virtually
every political topic and that's what I
think is so cool about what's happening
these days and I think it's probably why
you guys watch my show or you're
involved in in this whole thing that's
happening right now the example I like
is if you take two guys that I'm sure
you guys are familiar with ventia puro
and Sam Harris these guys disagree on
literally every political topic there is
from forget political topic they
disagree on the most existential
questions of the universe right whether
whether God exists and the value of
religion to abortion to taxes to
literally just down the line what
whatever you attack did the whole thing
get their allies now because there is a
massive realignment happening that if
you will agree on defending free speech
defending someone's ability to think and
live their life for themselves that in a
pluralistic society we're actually
supposed to disagree on those things so
I think that's a beautiful thing right
there but unfortunately we're sort of
only seeing tolerance one way these days
yeah and and and that the beauty of this
alliance is two things one is this idea
of freedom freedom of speech freedom of
thought but the second is that the
standard for truth is reason the reason
is the way in which we communicate
reason is the way in which we deal with
one another it you know it's not my god
versus your God and my revelation versus
your revelation no even if you're
religious like let's say Jordan Peterson
maybe is nobody's actually sure maybe
even though maybe even Jordans not
exactly sure well I'm going on tour with
them so there you go you'll find out
yeah but you know at the end of the day
the standard is reality the standard is
right and and the beauty of Steven
Pinker in his book is well yeah I think
there's some inconsistencies there some
ways in which he abandons reasons but he
venerates the idea of reason of reality
based thinking of facts and the same on
many issues ben shapiro right even when
we talk about politics or whether
there's a disagreement on politics we
agree that the standard should be what
is true what is actually in reality but
that that's why I think there's
something actually special going on here
and if you look here right we've got the
young Americans for liberty this is a
libertarian organization obviously
Turning Point USA a lot of their their
main guys or Trump supporters you're
you're not a trump supporter as an
understatement I voted for Gary Johnson
and I should be judged accordingly Gary
Johnson by the way he is the first
person that actually ever made me
question whether we'd should be legal or
not because the man could not remember
anything true but but this shows you
that there's a diversity of idea
happening right now on what I would say
is basically the sort of center-right
basically that I we could get into some
of our political differences I'm happy
to do that but that you guys are here
and that no matter what we say right now
you came because you wanted to hear
about some diverse ideas and
unfortunately I you know I offer this
all the time my next six months year
basically is full with speaking gigs and
not one is from a Democrat organization
or a left organization or a progressive
organization you know I'm gay married
that should have I'm not even gay I just
did it for the cred but but that should
have some cred with these people you
know I'm I'm pro-choice
you know we could go down the list I'm
for some social safety net that I know
we disagree on plenty of those things
that should get me some cred with the
left but unfortunately there there's a
real corruption in there in the side
that is always preaching about tolerance
and what I'm finding and I find it more
and more is I talk to these people who I
have massive disagreements with I'm sure
some of you guys saw Ben Shapiro on my
show where we we disagreed about
abortion and the death penalty
bunch of things but yet you guys invite
us here so that actually does say
something that's that's a real credit to
you and and we just aren't seeing this
on the left do you think it was always
like this
on the left because you I think for
young people and even for me it was yeah
sort of new I don't think it was always
like this on the left I think the left
was better in the past I think I think
the left indeed in many respects that
left was better than the right on the
issue of free speech and the right was
actually a press of a free speech for a
very long time so you're talking about
Berkeley 30 yeah I mean suddenly if you
go back to the 60s and sit but since
then and and and before the 60s there
was it there was definitely a sense in
which the left was much more open to new
ideas and look you know I think you're
more positive on the right than I am
because because you know so if you win a
CPAC this last year and it was a speak
at CPAC who spoke about who is some Cato
the Cato Institute and he said some
positive things about immigration you
would think he just said we should kill
all babies or something the room
exploded they booed him they try to get
him offstage and many of the people are
in that auditorium would have shut him
up if they could have done its I think I
think we were a little too you know too
positive about the rule is some people
on the right I I mean I was at an event
just before the election in Chicago and
this is this was like everybody was over
65 I was like a tea party group and I
was on stage and I said something
positive about immigration I I'm very
positive about immigration you can ask
about that and oh my god these 65 year
olds were standing up and cursing me and
yelling at me and try to get me off the
stage so there's a sudden intolerance
unfortunately Minoo I think it dominates
the left and it's in certain parts of
the right on certain issues and it's
it's scary because because again I mean
I think this group realizes this once
you lose the ability to speak that
basically once yet once your silence
they're basically limiting what you can
think and once you do that there were
right for authoritarianism it really is
the end of what we call Western
civilization which I think America's
still the
cannava still struggling to remain the
beacon of a dis is the issue of our time
there's no more important issue and this
is why this coalition has come together
yeah it's because this is the most
important issue I can think of is the
issue of free speech it Trump's
immigration warfare politics any of
these other issues if you can't speak
then you can't think and if you can't
think it's over I'm curious how many of
you guys saw just in the last couple
weeks the amount of articles from Vox
and salon and and all the usual players
who were sort of mocking the the free
speech fighters did you guys see that
yeah you know we'll do some of this by
applause just so the people at home can
get it did you guys see those articles
yeah I know you don't want to applaud
those articles specifically so that was
a little weird I suppose but I thought
that was really interesting that
suddenly and these again and you may be
right that I've been a little too easy
on elements of the of the right when it
comes to you know right for me it's like
I come from the left so when I see the
right when I see these the race realists
or these people that want America to be
a white state or it to me that is so
ridiculous and they have no
institutional power and they're they're
a bunch of true racists not the way that
racism is thrown at you guys
or at us yeah so to me those people
aren't even worth thinking about or even
it's just irrelevant so but perhaps you
you may be right that I've given them a
little bit of a slide there but what I
would say is it's interesting to me that
suddenly in the last couple weeks
there's been this push on the left media
to mock the free speech people the very
people who will defend these ridiculous
organizations like so on and and Vox to
to print these usually awful things I'm
sure many of you guys saw the articles
written about Jordan Peterson in the
last couple weeks yeah everyone's
nodding and it's like yeah I mean I find
it will defend their right to do it I'm
on the barricades I mean literally on
the barricades and you know I find it
interesting that they they get micro
aggressed I guess or they find offensive
certain things that we say yeah oh by
the way we have a room of puppies
against any of you
offended by any of the hate speech up
here tonight and cuddly teddy bears just
get something alive scares you but you
know but they can they can go after
Jordan Peterson offend him misrepresent
him or misrepresent Iran or missives and
me and we're not we don't we I get AG
rest I mean I get you know I get
triggered and nobody cares right what
about me
right you can insult me and there's like
if I say something on about about them
oh my god they're so sensitive but they
feel complete no problem insulting and
and really being violent against us and
we're supposed to just take it now let
me just say something about this left
right I think one of the reasons I'm
sensitive it in terms a more critical of
the right is because I'm perceived as a
member of the right and Iran is
perceived as belonging on the right and
and my and and I don't want to be I
don't want to be associated with Donald
Trump
I don't want to be associate with some
people on the right so when people right
like Sal Honda's often Trump's Iran
cabinet right I make a special effort to
make it clear that there's no
relationship between anybody on Trump's
cabinet and what Iran really meant so I
am much more sensitive to the nonsense
on the right because people want me to
belong I don't believe I'm on the left
or on the right I'm you know I think
we're like on a slightly different
dimension so I'm I'm clearly much more
sensitive about the right and I also
think I mean that's a whole lot of
question I also I think the right
there's a certain danger there as well
but yeah all right and I also you know
as I'm sure many of you guys have seen I
think these labels are getting
increasingly meaningless left right I'm
sure if we polled all of you guys that
your political opinions would be all
over the place and that's what it's
supposed to be that is what freedom is
supposed to be it's not supposed to be
ingrained into a political party but as
I saw all these articles about about
free speech and and you know they were
supposedly putting out polls that you
know students are more tolerant than
ever and then if you actually read them
it was that they were just intolerant of
racist speech which of course is insane
because they label everything they don't
like racist so it doesn't quite work but
by again by applause which is a little
bizarre how many of you on campus here
have been afraid to either say what you
think politically to a friend or a
faculty member or in class or anything
like that I know it's a weird thing to
applaud Wow yeah I got to figure out it
better but something else you should be
boos for that what's yeah boos is good
yeah boos is good but but that right
there shows it I mean I don't think the
same thing is if we were if I was
invited again if there was a progressive
group that would invite us here your own
and I would be happy to do it and I
think if I asked them you know how many
of you guys have been afraid to share
your opinions on intersectionality or
third wave feminism or whatever else it
is I'm pretty sure none of them are
having that issue and that's the survey
showed that the survey they were all
quoting says that people on the Left
don't believe that there's any problem
for them to express themselves but they
do recognize that conservatives or
anybody on the right do have a problem
expressing themselves so this survey
showed exactly this but what was
interesting is the way the survey was
phrased it was what do you what do you
see as more important free speech or
diversity and and diversity and
something else and you know inclusion
diversity and inclusion
first of all setting those two against
each other what is diversity and
inclusion even mean define your terms
right and then to set it up against free
speech and there a majority said
diversity inclusion are more important
than free speech which is shocking and
also just think what you know I know
many of you guys know this but just
think about what they mean by diversity
I could look around this room I see a
diverse group of people in color and
probably sexuality and ethnicity and
religion and all of that stuff how many
of you I mean is there anyone here that
wants to be judged by that your your
sexuality or your color or your religion
I mean religion is not an immutable
characteristic but they've sort of
dragged it as one I'll judge them based
on their yeah I'm the atheist in the
room
I mean there you go again so okay so we
have we have an atheist I mean I think
generally conservative there's an idea
that conservatives aren't that happy
with atheists but again you are invited
to all of these places so this actually
is what diversity is all about but but
shifting from that a little bit let's do
some hot-button things we touch on them
a little bit in the car the gun thing is
big obviously right now so you know
there was the parkland shooting it's
horrific
you know just watching what's happening
on Twitter now where they're taking all
of these kids and and that's what they
are they're kids
and they've suddenly become leaders of a
movement on both sides and I think
regardless of what your feelings are
about guns I think there's an absolute
danger in having young people who don't
have a full handle on the issues who've
experienced something horrible but that
doesn't make you an authority on how
legally we should be be guiding
ourselves but the gun issue seems to
have trumped everything else at this
prompt even Trump yeah I mean two things
one is relating to the the young people
I mean you guys have all grown up in an
educational system that has told you
that what you should value are your
emotions and how you feel you've gotten
ribbons for coming in last or whatever
right it's not to hurt yourself esteem
or anything I can't even say coming in
last there is no food there's no ladders
there is no and and what we see today is
exactly a reflection of that is adults
we are now venerating their motions of
sixteen year olds now they have emotions
and and it's true but what are the facts
what is the data what what are they what
are the rights issues involved let's
have a real conversation about it and I
get in trouble when I talk about guns
and including within the Objectivist
community a lot of people disagree with
me violently about guns I'm not a big
fan of guns I'm a you know this is from
a former IDF guy who used a lot of big
guns
I think you have a right to certain guns
but I don't think he ever right to any
kind of gun and a discussion about that
right and a real discussion about one of
the issues and how do you decide that
isn't happening right so on the one side
you get the people who say no
you know it it's you know it's a second
amendment that I get my ar-15 or
whatever right and and what about the
tank and what about the other stuff you
know where is the line nobody wants to
have the discussion of what is the line
right and then you have the other side
your ban everything and there's no
actual discussion about what is the role
of government is there a role of
government if there is a role of
government I think there is a role of
government cuz we're talking about
violence we're talking about weapons
we're talking about things that are
built for the purpose of violence how do
we have and and I don't have the answers
I actually this is one of those issues
well I don't have a clear usually I'm
like this is it yeah I don't have a
clear answer on the guns but I I know
that it's an interesting conversation to
have and there were a lot of deep issues
to be discussed and I don't see any of
that conversation happening out there so
I I was I was pulling out my phone not
because I was gonna tweet while you were
talking but but somebody tweeted
something at me on the way here actually
that I thought was really interesting
because I sent out a couple of tweets on
guns and he wrote people generally don't
understand why Second Amendment
absolutists fight against almost all gun
regulations in a vacuum they may even
think that some of those regulations are
appropriate but in a context where you
know the opposition will keep pushing
for more you have little choice but to
stand your ground and and I really
thought that captured it for me because
I'm not a huge gun guy in general I mean
the two places I've lived in my life
basically or New York City in LA I mean
I'm around liberals and not around a lot
of gun people I you know it this isn't
it's not even one of the issues it's
becoming a pet issue of mine because
it's so important right now but this
isn't something that I've I met you know
talked about in a really broad sense but
I thought that position was interesting
that knowing the way people operate now
that if you give an inch they will take
a mile and I'm sure some of you guys saw
at the at the rally the other day in DC
one of the the survivors was giving a
speech young girl and she basically said
we're gonna start with bump stocks and
then we're gonna keep going in effect
and we're gonna keep going till all guns
are banned and I thought that is how
these people operate and now they're
openly
saying it - and I know that's not a
position to say well I can't negotiate
that's not an ethical position to say I
can't negotiate but it's it it's a real
one it's a real issue and and but that
represents one of the great challenges
we have in our society where you you
can't have a conversation right and if
you can't have a conversation what are
we doing right and if you can't have a
conversation about guns and you can't
come up with a reasoned argument about
guns then what are we doing right I mean
that's just one issue and I don't think
that's any different than a discussion
about about a thousand other issues that
are out there with people cannot have a
conversation so so what's happening is
we're becoming tribal right there's the
gun guys who all gonna get together and
they're gonna be radical you know all
the way because they don't want to give
an inch because if they give it into
something will happen and then there's
the anti-gun people and that's it and
and and where do we go from that
perspective what is again I think what
loses its reason what loses is is the
ability to actually have a discussion
about an issue and think about it
thoroughly and deeply and we're becoming
tribal and on almost everything right
it's it's what are these guy you know I
belong to this group and they belong to
that group and they know no conversation
outlook there's certain issues where I
am I'm gonna stick 100% of my position
but it's not because it's not because I
would moderate that position if I
thought the other side no because I
think it's actually true and I'm not
gonna stick to a position I know is
false because I'm afraid of the other
side you know forcing me into a
compliment right because I think that's
a nice take but a lot of people will I
you know we oh yeah and that's why
critical thinking is so important
because I even though I understood the
the idea behind that person's tweet I
don't want to be in that position where
I start defending things that I don't
like just because I hate the other side
I think that that's where so many people
so many people happen to be these days
you know what I'm gonna let you pick the
next topic haha we said we'd bounce back
and forth what else is on your mind at
the moment Wow
I mean there's this I mean right now on
my mind is probably
I mean the thing I talk about mostly
right now is trade because of what
because of what what what Trump is doing
it which i think is you know is is
bizarre and absurd and ridiculous so you
know I don't I mean it's not fair
because I don't know that you've you
know you have a position of thought
about it bit but yeah go ahead youtuber
I thought about it may you go that's
right come on it's babe Rubin she's
thought about it I'm sure I can take
trade and make it into a demon or
disease you and topic do it somehow I
will be able to what are the chances we
get monetized right now on YouTube what
do you think we talked about guns so
probably all right so we're are as long
as guns are not in the title but but
they you know they run the algorithms
and they find guns and your office well
you know I watched watch I'll bleak the
move there I'm curious how many of you
even think that the YouTube situation
and the Facebook situation Saudi
monetization tracking you guys all that
how many of you think that act that
actually may be second to free speech as
your own laid out is really the issue of
the day how many of you really think
that that's that one you didn't applaud
for but you all raise your hands okay
yeah yeah
so a lot of you do think so so so this
is something we'd disagree I don't know
if you disagree on so you know I think
we agree on but others you know so so I
think I think what YouTube is doing is
awful I think what Facebook does is
awful I think all that's awful and I
think it's a right to do it I think it's
their property it's their business they
created it and if they want to mess it
up and they want to screw it up if they
want to exclude me then they have every
right to do that right and and it's up
up to us and we're you know to come up
with an alternative say you know if the
you know I forget who the entrepreneur
started YouTube is but he created
something and Google runs it and they
own it and they get a set the rules and
if they don't like what we say or they
don't want to de monetize it it hurts
but they have a you know sorry actually
think that prego suing YouTube is really
really bad for the cause of free speech
it muddies the water about what free
speech really is it it takes away this
differentiation between what is public
and what is private so I I'm with your
own on that not you guys I think know my
feelings about Dennis Prager
I love Dennis have you ever done any
events
I mean oh no all right well let's see if
we can make that happen I'll see
interesting
I'd love to facilitate that though and I
think I probably I didn't event years
ago with with we were both on a panel
together and yeah it got heated very
quickly all right but that's what it's
all about right so I I agree with your
premise there that these companies can
of course do whatever they want I tweet
this constantly and then people always
say to me Oh a libertarian who's saying
that why are you complaining you're not
supposed to complain because you don't
want government involvement I say that's
actually the you're making the reverse
point of course you're supposed to use
your voice in a free society to
hopefully influence these companies I
feel like I'm gonna that's gonna be the
one that I'm gonna have to just tweet
for the rest of my life well and we
should stop using Twitter for that
offended yeah I mean if we really think
the Twitter is doing something horrible
then the best way is to boycott I mean
we had this conversation on your show
about what to do about the Baker right
so I believe that you should have a
right to discriminate about anything
right and not just it towards gays but
towards people you don't like or
anything no Jews allowed is is is I
think okay to put up as a sign in your
store I don't think anybody should go
into that store I think we should all
boycott right and I think that's the
appropriate way in which you deal with
the business that does something you
don't like but they have a right to do
it it's their property I have a right to
invite anybody I want to my home it's my
property and believe me I have very
strict I'll put it this way my wife has
very stringent criteria but who gets
invited to a home or not yeah I've never
been invited to your home well you you
invited my wife likes you yeah but in
Puerto Rico now and you can ask me about
Puerto Rico if you want but because I
live in Puerto Rico no but he hates
taxes so you have a white where's the
fog who you know pay the taxes so a
stole my business is just an extension
of my home it's mine that's what it
means that private property it's mine
and I have a right to do what I want
with it including be stupid and
irrational and suicidal and
discriminatory and evil and bad as long
as I'm not punching somebody in the nose
even a Nazi as long as I'm not punching
somebody in the nose I have a right to
do it and the way to deal with that is
to boycott those businesses and
ultimately if we really get to the point
where Twitter is we will boycott Twitter
and we'll find a solution I you really
believe in all of our ingenuity to be
able to find ways around these
businesses they will not dominate us so
I have a slightly different point of
view on this but but I think it's a rich
place for a conversation so look you
know I did my Prager you video and I've
talked about why I wouldn't force the
government to force the Baker to make
the cake right you can get a cake
elsewhere I would say that you know one
of the things that we still have in this
country at least for now is the foot
vote we have states rights and if you
don't like something that's happening in
your state you can go to another state
this is a beautiful thing if we if we
did not have that you'd have to leave
the country or you can come to Puerto
Rico or you can go to Puerto Rico I'm
not do they have any gay bakers in
Puerto Rico I'm not sure but I don't
think they put of gay bacon probably but
I personally would not have the Baker
the government forced the Baker to
provide a specific service now you're
actually taking it a step further
because what you're saying is it's not
about a specific service like in this
case it's a it's a cake that maybe he
doesn't normally make so that's a
specific service you're saying actual if
he doesn't want gay people to be in his
store he doesn't have to be now we have
the Civil Rights Act of I think 1964 yep
yep and that elects t3 or 60 64 64 okay
which that forced businesses not to
discriminate based on on color and and
several other characteristics I'm okay
with that because at the time there was
so much discrimination
and so much inequity and there were
still laws on the books in different
states that allowed for it that this is
an odd case where I think the federal
government did the right thing where I
think there's an interesting libertarian
or Objectivist argument to make against
that in 2018 which i think is your
argument so I would say that certainly
the federal government had a role in 64
to play and and I support most of the of
the civil rights act and they suddenly
had a responsibility amal response
really legal response to be a
constitutional responsibility to make
sure that all the states got rid of
whatever discriminatory laws they had
that that's what the civil war was about
and if hundred years later we still have
to fight that battle it's horrific
right the federal government has a
responsibility to make sure the states
are not in a significant way violating
individual rights and discriminating by
law but I don't believe the federal
government or state government or any
government has a right to impose they
will on my private property and even if
you can make an argument that you needed
a corrective action in 1964 which I
don't support I don't support because I
think once you do it it's a slippery
slope and you get the Baker you get you
get these situations it there's no way
to avoid it and not only that but you
get the situation where the government
today can tell me who to employ under
what conditions to employ what who I can
fire when I can't find you know today
there's ageism and there's a million
isms that determine who I can fire and
hire you know I can be sued in
California for five somebody who's older
because it's ageism oh sorry you know so
there's no end to that and that is the
slippery slope of the 64 Civil Rights
Act so but even if you assumed okay you
need a corrective measure in 64 okay
it's gone enough is enough and I also
think that a lot of the rise of the of
the racist right today is a consequence
it's a backlash of the identity politics
of the left which in and all of that is
institutionalized into the Civil Rights
Act so affirmative action is a racist
policy it's a racist policy
well it's corrective enough it's racist
once you adopt as a federal government a
racist policy then who's to say
that racism is not okay you know on the
left and on the right and what you're
seeing is I think it's legitimized the
rise of a new form of racism that is
widespread in this country which by the
way if you guys want to see how this is
so how this actually creeps up into all
of these businesses you know I'm sure
many of you saw this but Google is now
has a lawsuit involved because they had
a practice of not hiring Asian or white
male engineers that actually is racism
and should be hiring people based on
whoever's most qualified but you
shouldn't be saying we are literally I
mean that is literally what they were
gonna do they were not gonna hire white
males or Asian males I mean I can look
out here there were some Asian people
that means you would be less inclined to
get a job because of what you look like
that is actually the definition of
racism so the more this enough gets
institutionalized the more we're
actually going to see the rise of this
identitarian right and that's what we're
trying a neutral and and of course
there's a debt to Tyrion left and it's
it's all playing off and I think it
really gets legitimized by the 64 act
and look Berkeley Berkeley does the same
thing it doesn't take more Asians
because I think 40 percent have broke
Lee's Asians and they've like said
enough we need diversity so in the name
of diversity they're taking less
qualified students in the name of this
diversity thing so no I I think it I
think the the 64 I mean I supported I
support I you know I was alive then but
very little so I didn't support
Goldwater but Ironman supported
Goldwater and Goldwater agreed with most
of the civil rights I'd accept that
portion they that book that basically
intervene in private property and
created affirmative action he was you
know he was Goldwater was not a racist
so he believed that you know we should
get rid of any kind of institutionalized
racism but you don't get rid of
institutionalized racism by creating
reverse institutionalized racism that
just perpetuates the racism problems I
feel like we should talk a little bit
about how this also crushes creativity
because I'm sure many of you saw this
Peter teal is taking his companies and
he's leaving Silicon Valley he's leaving
San Francisco right
mean the guy's worth about four billion
dollars he can't even afford to live
there anymore I mean that that's a
that's a real problem I thought that was
funnier no but but I think what he
realized there is that this this
diversity memo that was forcing him to
either hire a certain way that wasn't
based in qualification what that will
actually do to creativity I think I
think Iran certainly had a lot to say
about this well again it's it's freedom
what creativity depends on is is is
freedom it's the I it's the idea of
coming up with whatever ideas using your
reason being judged based on the quality
of the ideas based on the truth of the
ideas but not based on the color of your
skin not based on whether your woman or
man not based on any of these irrelevant
criteria but just on the quality of what
you are creating and you can't do that
anymore right you you you can't talk in
some of these corporate environments
particularly in Silicon Valley about
anything outside of the box anything
that doesn't fit into some frame of
people who call themselves leftist I
guess and and I look I love Silicon
Valley in many respects I think Silicon
Valley is the model for America I mean
they're the hardest-working most
creative most innovative most exciting
people in the planet but isn't that the
irony it should be a vegetarian yes it
should be or it secretly is I think it's
possible I think I think that more kind
of free market free thinkers in Silicon
Valley then give it credit for
but it's this oppressive leftist kind of
ideology particularly on social issues
that does not allow those people to even
speak up now you know you know the
Google memo that de Muro you know now I
don't necessarily agree with what was
written in the memo but that memo was
pretty lame I mean it was pretty
uninteresting right he said some stuff
that a lot of evolution I said calls
just that I don't necessarily agree
would say it's it this was not radical
it was not crazy
and yet he gets fired for writing
something yeah yeah a lot of people
could easily disagree with but that's a
great conversation to have about the
difference
men and women is a fascinating
conversation even if as I'm saying this
I'm dreading the idea of actually having
that conversation because it's so scary
right but it's it's a fascinating
conversation to have and you can't have
it because there's a dogma that says
there no differences but but of course
their differences just look around the
room we're different
right and and the idea that biological
differences don't have manifestation
psychologically and in other ways is
absurd
right so but we can't you know if I said
that in front of certain audiences yeah
third wave feminism or whatever they
come after me right well what's even
more dangerous about that is that Google
asked James to write the memo in effect
you know they were all sent to these
courses and they were asked well what do
you think about this let us know and I'm
sure I don't know the numbers but I
would venture to say that 90% of the
employees that went to these things
probably never did what they were
supposed to do they probably went
they're probably worth tweeting half the
time and went to sleep and then this guy
actually listened he goes this is a
problem at this company I'm gonna do
what I'm supposed to do I'm gonna
respond he then sent it out privately by
the way this is one of the biggest
misnomers about and he wasn't fired when
he sent it out privately no and then
someone else leaked it he wasn't looking
for attention he I mean he did exactly
what the company told him to do I
believe this was the end of August by
the way he had just been given a
promotion for good work in June he was
fired by what October it was fired
because of the public pressure on Google
it wasn't even within Google I mean some
people within Google clearly want him in
route but it was the outcry among among
the the you know that the people who
supposedly count in Silicon Valley the
diversity Chiefs at all these
organizations that really got him fired
it wasn't even with the while he was
just in Google nobody seemed to really
care and by the way did you guys see
this other thing a couple months ago I
think it was YouTube but somebody
correct me if I'm wrong
there was an Asian woman that was hired
as the diversity offer officer for you -
yes she said that she wanted diversity
of thought and that includes white men
and then she was forced to step down in
a week she really think was it YouTube a
literally said she wants diversity of
thought
and it it she didn't care for as a man
woman Asian black you know whatever the
thing she just wanted the versity of
thought and she thought that good
thinking wasn't associated with the
color of your skin and she was fired for
that I think it was you - yeah I think
was good eat within Google again okay
I'm getting a couple maybe not no oh it
was Apple it was Apple Apple no no but
anyway it may not have been YouTube
anyway sure the using Google identity
very friendly to us on this error
somebody is tweeting you right now the
only thing they're acting a mistake but
yeah it was definitely she was
definitely that's exactly what she said
and and she was accused of that so
there's a pulley there's almost this
this in it and it's not a majority of
people I mean III know lots of people in
Silicon Valley you don't believe any of
this crap right but there is a it's a
it's the culturally important people in
some way right who guide this and
they're intolerant they've been tolerant
to any view that is not fit their view
of the world and it's it's horrific so
let's shift a little bit someone yeah
where we are just we've got another six
minutes Q&A so I think the other issue
that that is huge right now that I think
your generation you deflected the trade
stuff oh yeah well I noticed it that's
good um thank you good job yeah
trade yes yes no boring who the hell
nobody watches that's why he has
hundreds of thousands of you know that's
the difference are you gonna do a subtle
movement saying much sexier which is the
crumbling of mainstream media and we can
mock CNN how about that I'm a crowd
pleaser you know trade yeah let's see
can I defend I can I defend mainstream
media for a second oh yeah go ahead I
mean so I agree with all the criticism
on mainstream media but the fact is the
fact is that the only people who
actually have reporters out there the
only people who have people out there
around the world actually you're trying
to report news and many of them don't
report news they report bias but is the
mainstream media now I think that
horrible and awful
the fact is that in terms of news not in
terms of commentary this commentary you
have all the options in the world but in
terms of actually knowing what's going
on in the world what's tragic is we have
no alternative right if you actually
want to know what's going on right now
in Cairo nobody other than CNN or the
New York Times has anybody there and
that makes the bias even worse because
there's and the idea of objective
journalism I don't know if anybody hears
in journalism school
nobody right through his notebook in the
back yeah
nobody not a single person I mean almost
every school is probably represented
here but journalism in English maybe is
not I mean then they're not taught
objective reporting they're not taught
that there is such a thing as objective
reality so it's not even that I believe
namma blame their professors who've
taught them this garbage but we don't
even actually have information coming in
that's reliable so I actually read all
the mainstream media I have to because
there's no alternative if there's nobody
else yeah so your honor makes a couple
interesting points there so first you're
right in terms of reporting you know I
get people that come up to me I was out
once with Ben and somebody came up said
oh you're the only you guys are the only
people I trust and I was like man if
that's true I'm trying man people out in
the field in Cairo you know although I
tweet with the guy in Cairo but you know
what I'm saying like and what been done
is commentary for the most part he
doesn't actually precisely if you news
right so and and Ben wouldn't deny that
by the way I think daily wire does a
nice job of doing news but I don't know
how many people they have on the field
out you know someone it most of even
that is interpretation so but this is
this is the strange place were in we're
now reliant on very few people that are
actually doing true reporting and true
journalism there are a couple by the way
I Tim Poole who I'm sure some of you
guys know I think is is one of the best
but what is now passed as news you know
I don't watch CNN anymore sometimes I
put it on mute and I played a loon
theme song but what what is every now
and again I'll be at the gym and CNN's
on and I just watch with would you watch
rocks no I don't watch any of them but
yes I don't want you anyway
I mean Fox is just as bad but what I
read biases that way however we don't
which is the only network that'll put
either one of us on it's Fox Fox won't
put me on anymore oh no it got to me
yeah I mean during the elections they
wanted me to endorse a candidate and I
refused I said I don't like any of them
and I and I and because I wouldn't
endorse a candidate and then in 2012
because I was criticizing Republicans
they literally told me that because I
was criticizing Republicans they would
not have me six months before the
election I was banned from Fox so so
what I would say is the reason I focused
on CNN more is because everyone knows
what MSNBC is everyone knows what
they're not pretending I'm pretty sure
you look at what network Hannity's on
what are these people about you know
like I don't think it's really like that
right but but CNN is pretending yes and
I think that that's the bigger problem
because you can watch virtually any show
on CNN and what they're passing as news
really is 24/7 Trump hysteria and I'm
obviously sitting again next to somebody
who shares some of those views but that
they're trying to gin us all up into so
for very different reasons very
different different yeah but but that
they're trying to gin us all up into
caring about things that don't matter as
opposed to caring about the things that
do matter which is why you will never
see conversations like this on CNN you
the amount of traction that a guy like
Jordan Peterson who's get getting by
talking about psychology and telling you
to clean your room my room has never
been cleaner by the way after spending
some time with this guy he still needs
to work on me obviously but but that is
what's happening here there is a
disconnect between the people that are
supposedly giving you news and what you
guys are realizing the truth is and the
fact that there's about 20 of us that
seem to be trying to offer a defense on
that is actually scary to me and my my
view is this is be going off a long time
it's just people have just realized it
but but I remember 20 years ago CNN was
just as biased as it is today just
people didn't realize
it was in this counter I you know I
don't know how many of you ever listen
to BBC the BBC's nutty left I mean it's
crazy left but it's the only again only
news source if you want global news or
if you read The Economist again The
Economist even is pretty left but if you
want to read about what's going on
Africa that's the only source there is
and and the left has dominated the news
sources throughout and they bias so I
listen I don't watch any television I
hate television news I can't stand to
start throwing things Fox CNN CNBC
doesn't matter I you know it there's
something visceral about the image but I
listen to NPR I listen to NPR a lot
although in Puerto Rico less so but she
cuz it's just you know and put her
because just relaxed do you know who
wants to listen to NPR when you relaxed
baby and I actually find it really good
because they're intellectual they report
stories nobody else reports on they're
biased
they're obviously biased I've now got a
bias radar and I correct for the bias
whenever it comes across but I read the
New York Times and in the other times
it's all biased and you can read it and
you can adjust for everything and it's
sickening because it really and but then
you go okay so what do I read you know
where can I get any kind of information
not a Breitbart
right and and and so there's there is no
objective reporting out there there's no
and it hasn't been for a long time I
mean this is a scary thing is this is
not new this is just being discovered I
think by some people but it's it's that
the the the bias on the left is being
around I mean you you guys don't
remember but when Ronald Reagan ran for
president there were only three networks
there was no other television news the
ABC NBC and it was no internet so the
only news you could get the only news
you could get was ABC NBC and CBS and
PBS right and they were radically anti
Reagan I mean they would make you think
they're making fun of Trump they would
make fun of Reagan constantly right and
there was no alternative this is all
there was and Reagan's like a giant as
compared to trump like so-so
in some sense it's even more biased so I
actually think we're better in some ways
better today because I think this bias
is being going on for a long time and
today there's at least voices that
recognize the bias and they're talking
about the bias so in that sense I think
actually the media landscape is better
because we have an Internet because your
show people actually discuss ideas and
is there's the in hundreds you know more
people watch your show than many of the
network stuff so you know we actually
blessed today in the fact that
technology has made it possible faster
broaden our horizons in ways that didn't
exist 20 years ago 10 years yeah if you
guys want a little more on this I'm sure
some of you saw it already but the I
believe the second time I had Eric
Weinstein on he talks about the four
types of news and what four types of
fake news and one of the one of them is
that he says you know it's not just what
they're saying that can often be faked
but it's what they won't say so for
example when it happened to be his
brother Brett Weinstein at evergreen
college I'm sure many of you guys are
all nodding already so you know the
story and I'm sure everyone at home
knows the story Brett a guy who had
fought racism his whole life at
Evergreen of perhaps the most left
college in all of America he said that
no we can't tell students not to come to
class one day because of the color of
their skin he was actually fighting
racism the times did not report on that
for weeks and months and yet at one
point had written two or three op-eds
about it so they didn't want it to be in
their news section but then they could
offer it a very tepid defense from a
sort of liberal op ed position and that
also is a type of fake news if they just
sort of ignore one position you know but
just it just to be you know just because
we haven't touched on any controversial
issues I mean just think about the
Middle East right if Israel in in some
context shoots a Palestinian that's
front-page news all over the world if
Egypt bombs what they call terrorists in
the Sinai and they kill hundreds of
people it doesn't make a single news
agency nobody knows that Egypt has been
bombing the hell out of the Sinai for
the last two years trying to eradicate
Isis from there put it put aside whether
it's just enough the very fact that
they're doing it nobody cares nobody
puts it it's completely silent and
there's so much of that going on in the
world we only know we only hear about a
tiny little sliver of what's going on
and you know one of the things i think
steven pinker again if we can end maybe
we're gonna end on Steven
one of the things he points out is we
never hear about the good stuff all the
good news like I I say my talks probably
the most important news story of the
last 30 years right that nobody talks
about is the fact that over the last
thirty years a billion people have come
out of poverty in the world because by
the way of capitalism and New York Times
York Times doesn't report that I mean
all the graphs that he has in that book
should be front-page that's the most
interesting important stuff going on in
the world the eradication of hunger the
eradication of extreme poverty through
market forces and nobody ever puts that
but we hear every little thing like
every you know violence is it an
all-time low in the United States right
now right but every little motor
particularly if it's committed by a
illegally it you know immigrant it is
reported on immediately right again
depending on the media source who
reports and who doesn't and that is so
tragic because we don't actually have an
objective view of the state of the world
or what's going on in the world or what
are the real dangers how many people
report about free speech issues right
the New York Times doesn't love with
that well the guys that do seem to be
salon and box all right that seem that
seems like a fitting ending I would say
this just to put a cap on it which is
that it's up to you guys like the
pressure is truly on you guys you know
like you guys live you're going to
college in a incredibly unique time
right now these issues I mean I was
smoking pot and playing Sega Genesis for
four years in college I wish in a weird
way I wish I had paid more attention
you were before pot I guess but what you
guys are truly at school at an
incredibly unique time because the
things that you're thinking
about are the exact same things that
everyone your parents your grandparents
everyone you know everything is up in
the air right now and you guys truly I'm
not saying this to pander like I would
not do what I do if I didn't think that
there was a chance we could correct this
thing but the only way that guys like us
can be a little part of the correction
is if we have more people like you so I
thank you guys for coming out
give a big round of applause so you can
pull at home for watching and let's do
some QA did you agree with like you know
it should have been done the government
shouldn't need screening but firing
businesses and you know people have a
right to do that but just you know the
government really because if you go the
DMV or you go wherever government we
don't do those things you know they just
scream again so you can't really do
think about obviously but you know if
it's anything private you know then that
should be up the business well I know
your answer on this you know I'll let
you field it but I think we're in
complete agreement yeah I mean my view
is government should absolutely not
discriminate I think the government's
job to go back to my opening statement
is to protect individual rights the
individual rights of every human being
we're all equal in our right to life
liberty property and the pursuit of
happiness and you don't you you don't
protect rights by violating some
people's rights oh you can't do that so
gummin no now I will challenge one thing
I don't think the government needs to do
the DMV I don't think the government
needs to do 90% of what it does today so
we can we can privatize all that but but
yes government should never discriminate
that is a real evil that needs to be
fought we weren't going to do a whole
line ran event without someone saying
get rid of the DMV where we know it's a
key feature of that philosophy
[Music]
I am an anarcho-capitalist my question
is at the end of the day anybody who
takes his own life seriously anybody who
uses reason to guide a life to make
their life the best life that it can be
and rejects the altruistic guilts and
the the the unreason that dominates our
culture can be a jungle that would have
been pretty hilarious if he would have
been like so regarding you said that you
support so having as many private
businesses as possible as opposed to
public areas is that correct
so if given those two conditions
wouldn't that mean that each would
always be a it would it be please speech
book business person authorized to speak
no because I mean in a sense yes there's
a sense in which that's true but look
free speech is a limitation on
government the First Amendment is a
limitation on government because it's a
limitation on force you ever you have
the ability to use your home and
particularly today right I mean again
modern technology has made so many of
these issues kind of bogus I gets it in
my computer and and generate videos on a
multiple platform ignoring YouTube I can
I can probably start my own platform I
mean probably people who could help me
program that and get it out there so as
long as it's a private business is not
restricting your speech at private
businesses determining what it allows
down and it's private property and
that's its right so it's not business
granted speech it's you know your speech
is up to you and it's your
responsibility to find the delivery
mechanism for you know in there was in
the old days the idea of equal time on
on radio and TV I forget the name of the
fairness the Fairness Act and the idea
was all station I mean and I her end
actually supported that as a counter to
all you know the bias that existed that
she so but you know how many opinions is
that does that respect right what is the
finish act I'm an Objectivist that I get
do I get equal time with with the
leftist or with the communist or with
the way do i how do you even do that
it's impossible to actually allocate
time if you know in that kind of sense
and no this is something where the
government has no role in the wall of
the government is to protect you from
somebody literally silencing you on your
property and the the main reason why the
First Amendment exists is because
throughout history government has
silenced people and and in Europe right
now I mean we talk about the US but
Europe is in much worse situation than
the US he saw that in the UK but Europe
generally because they have hate speech
laws and you know the massacre and
Charlie Hebdo when they went and killed
all the cartoonist well the French
government was trying to shut down
Charlie Hebdo just the weeks before that
because Charlie Hebdo was offensive to
all these things religion and everything
else right and the French government was
trying to do it so defense government in
that sense were allied with the with the
you know the Islamists and so that's the
real dangers when when when not only
were the French gum and not protect the
cartoonists from the Islamists but when
the French government itself is trying
to shut down the the cartoon shop yeah
very quickly on the Google Twitter front
of this there's interesting arguments to
be made because Google that particularly
controls so much of our information
right now I fall more in line with what
your on saying but I think you guys I
mean get turning point right behind me
get them to invite Dennis Prager here to
talk about that because he also comes
from a libertarian perspective
conservative person to a debate
obviously has a different debate
happily I I will say anything I will set
up and yeah first my first up I just
wanted to say it I'm a huge fan and this
is a bit of an abstract question and I
want to say so I completely believe in
the power of the individual but I think
it's also inevitable that culture itself
is collectivist especially in the modern
world like you see like all these like
groups on campus and everything that are
just so identity politics base so I
don't think it's always been that way so
I just wanted to ask about your
perspectives on how it became that way
how individual of them has become so
antagonized and why that's such like an
equal like especially as a great
question yeah I mean well let's both
take a stab quickly I would say this
it's simply lazy thinking that is the
easiest and most honest answer it is
lazy thinking to to look at you and you
have brown skinned what can i discern
from you from that other than your skin
color absolutely you like hurry okay
you like hurry I like Indian food there
you go all right we can go for dinner
after this but but really if I was to
look at you and think think that I know
anything else about you other than that
right now right you're you're a woman
you have long hair I mean the things
that I can see those are the things that
you can tell by looking at somebody but
to think that you know more about
somebody because of that if right if I
was taking the leftist view of this I'd
look at you and go oh well she's brown
skin so she must be a progressive and
sheep you know and ba-ba-ba-ba-ba that
is actually prejudice that is prejudging
that is the essence of what what where
racism and xenophobia comes from so this
whole thing that we're fighting is based
in lazy thinking if you actually
we care about people if you care to sit
down across from somebody and look them
in the eye as I'm doing with you now you
will learn a lot more about people and
you will have all of your your your your
own prejudices will melt pretty quickly
and it's actually the antidote to racism
to believe in the individual that's so
so I mean I agree with all of them and
let me let me I think it's important for
us to really because I think we take
certain things for granted individualism
is a huge achievement it's an
achievement it's an ideological
achievement so the human race has been
collectivistic from for however long you
want to count the human race as being
around right we were tribal we hated the
other tribe you know Jews hated
everybody else everybody else hated Jews
I mean this is the way it's been forever
and then these thinkers came about
during the Enlightenment right and they
said no all of that is wrong because all
of that is based basically an emotion
it's lazy thinking it's non thinking
really no we all have this capacity to
reason we all have this capacity think
as individuals we can't eat as a group
we don't have a collective stomach we
simply don't have a collective brain and
for the first time in human history
really during the 18th century and even
they were flawed because they started
had had slavery these thinkers came up
and said no individuals are the the the
mollow unit the sacred unit the thing
that is most important because they can
think for themselves they can use their
own reason to judge and evaluate the
world remember before that we you know
all of human history's tribal
authoritarian you know dictatorship
which God do you believe in that
dictated everything so for the first
time this period and I think I think
it's never gotten a full defense this
idea of individualism and it's never
been grounded and what has happened is
that knowledge that came about in the
Enlightenment they first start the
adoration of reason and the the
understanding of reasons role in human
life has slowly been eroded primarily by
German philosophers and the
romantic tradition and so on and when we
abandon reason we were abandoned
thinking
the default is tribalism
the default is collectivism so you have
to think about it that's the default
individualism is an achievement and what
we need is to resurrect the ideas of the
Enlightenment this is why I love Pincus
book right even if I don't agree with
everything in it the idea that the
Enlightenment is what we should aspire
towards is the right idea we can we can
all give out the details later but it's
the idea of individual reason and a
fixie of reason and importance of reason
that's the battle it's not political
that's why I can I can love Steven
Pinker it's biota factor politically
probably votes or something completely
different than me but it's the adoration
of Reason and the Enlightenment that's
what it's about and we have to recognize
that there's an achievement because
otherwise we get lazy Oh individualism
well that's easy right no I mean it took
a hundred thousand years of human
history to come up with the idea of
individualism and and it's too easily
dismissed and we need to fight for it
that's the real battle thank you it's in
the works we were talking to his people
is that right requires the coercion of
either directly of the healthcare
provider or indirectly of the tax payer
and therefore it is tantamount to
slavery and that one cannot have a right
to enslave that to exercise a right if
you must if you have to infringe upon
somebody else's right to do it it can't
be your right
well I'm very sympathetic to that
argument but what the speedbump that I'm
running into as I think through this cuz
I don't like about shift points I like
chef things for our current legal system
guarantees one the right to an attorney
if they're accused of
crime and also right to trial by jury
both of which would then coerce the it's
very least the time and labor of another
so my question is what am I missing
is it mislabeled as a right is it a
different kind of right and how is it
fundamentally different than the alleged
right to health care Wow that right
there is a guy who knows why I asked a
question well I mean that was a
beautiful question you and nighttimes
did a beautiful question I've never
heard it before yeah and and it was it
was really well formulated laid out
eight questions and I haven't even and I
haven't thought about it in that context
so it's it's it's a new thing for me to
think about I I think first of all that
we have to rethink about the whole idea
of a right you know the whole idea of a
jury I'm not convinced of that that is
truly a right and and you know just
because just because somebody said a
long time ago that something's a right
doesn't make it a right
I think thinking through exactly the way
you prescribed it one ask the question
is that a real is it a right in that
sense but you know if you accept that
right then if you accept the right the
jewelry is the same kind of course of
activity then you have a right to food
and you every way you have all the
positive rights and that and and
everything collapses and I think you
have to question and I don't have an
answer for you right at the end of the
day I'm happy to say I don't know
because I haven't really thought about
it
you have to question whether you would
categorize the right to a jury and the
right to a publicly paid attorney as as
real right and what would be the
alternative and how you know you have a
right to be treated justly right that
you have a right to and what is justice
require and justice can require the
coercion of other people so one has to
think through and it would have what
would one would have to solve that
problem but I wouldn't use that to
undercut everything else I would just
say there's an issue there to think
about and there's an issue there to
solve not that gives me now the right to
coerce everybody into doing whatever the
hell I want in the name of Rights
you don't empty the concept of rights
just because there's a not a clear
understanding how to apply it to a
particular area and clearly I don't have
that which one of my philosophy friends
were here philosophers of law and on how
that how the issue of Rights applies to
the jury in the other issue but again
don't be tempted by something you don't
know and don't know exactly how to apply
by throwing up the whole concept which
is what if you apply the right to health
care then then you forget about because
there's so many well that one's true
[Music]
yeah I just want to see yeah well I
appreciate your question because I am
someone that comes from the left right I
mean I was a progressive basically my
whole life I worked at the Young Turks I
mean I I understand what that thinking
is and I'm sure most of you guys you
know know my basic story but I started
seeing an absolute collapse of thinking
of intellectualism of honest brokering
of basically not always assuming the
worst motives of all of your opponents
but actually thinking you know these
people might just think differently and
we got to sit down with them so without
going too far down the rabbit hole of
Russia gate what I would say is if if
you are struggling to debate properly on
facts
you will go down every rabbit hole there
is and I think that unfortunately
there's a lot of these days especially
because of the way we get news there's a
lot of rabbit holes to go down and
that's just one of the other yeah well
first of thank you for your service I
would say quickly on that that I tweeted
out that day I mean if you're a
libertarian or a classical liberal of
course you should be disappointed by
Trump signing this thing and of course I
mean government all the government does
is make big budgets so that it can reach
those budgets so it can spend that money
so that it can get more money the only
way we can push back on this I mean
people thought that Trump was gonna
somehow magically come in and and not do
that and it's exactly what he's done so
if you really want limited government
you have to stop voting for people that
believe that government the answer I
think Trump kind of tricked people a
little bit on this but you should vote
for more people like austin peterson
who's running for senate in missouri
yeah I love Austin I mean that that's
the only thing you can do a on the
YouTuber part I you know I don't think
there's some sort of grand conspiracy
I mean I'll certainly talk about it more
on my show I would have loved to have
seen something that would have been a
20-3 guy I mean just naming a number 20%
cut across the board on everything guess
what the government will still function
you know and if the post office closes
tomorrow I'm pretty sure Amazon could
figure it out so there's but but
everyone's afraid to say well we're
gonna have to do some of that stuff and
let's see what happens and I think your
own would say that the private sector
could step in in almost every case yeah
in almost everything except the military
because I think that is a function a
legitimate function of government and I
do talk about the fact that our military
budget as is is way overblown if we
actually let the military win wars
instead of building so-called
you know building societies building
democracies and we've got troops in 120
different countries not 120 different
countries are not threat to the United
States
very few are indeed given the size of
our military know we should be shrinking
military spending but coalescing it
around really defending America bringing
troops home and really actually you know
I'm a hawk when it comes to the military
and and this is the thing that the Trump
supposedly signed the budget because
he's so pro military and and so he you
know you'd let them spend all this other
stuff so but no even on the military you
shouldn't be spending this money I agree
with you completely and I do talk about
it I think generally I don't find a lot
of YouTube unfortunately under more
economic issues there's a lot on the
social issues on free speech which is
great because I do think free speech is
the most important issue there's just
not a lot on the economic issues I think
there's a lot of lack of understanding
of the economic issues thank you
we have about 15 more all right well
we're gonna try to do one minute with
you we'll try to get there but thank you
guys so much for coming you guys
mentioned journalism and you mentioned
Silicon Valley but you didn't mention
the Hollywood and I'm a film major I'm
about to graduate enter the yeah I
wanted to know your advice on on that
anything in particular I'm looking at
jobs at the sea and unfortunately that's
the closest thing to me
if you advise staying silent and you
just go in under the radar because my
film industry as I am or being more
vocal about it and being a little bit
braver and trying to affect some change
I just I'm so yeah well I'm pretty sure
you just lost the job at CNN by doing
this on my channel but okay forget that
I I would say don't worry about them
they are a dying dinosaur we are
watching them sink into the La Brea Tar
Pits right now get on YouTube get it I
mean I'm some guy that started a YouTube
channel that's it right you all can do
that open a Twitter I mean all that
stuff
get on there start making great films
put it out there tweet at me if it's
good I'll retweet yeah I mean that's
really it you don't need them anymore
they're dying let's let them die and
figure out what comes next and don't and
believe me at how old you 19 maybe
you're 22 if you're going to compromise
that 22 you will compromise way more at
33 and 44 and 55 so why would you
compromise now just get out there and do
it I don't think you can beat that
answer
so with free market there tends to be
some sort of compulsion in the grand
scale of focusing on capital gains
opposed to potentially positive social
movements for example mass media
covering like the bad news that posted
the good news in terms of YouTube kind
of censoring the stuff that may cause
worry is there a way for the free market
to practically solve backers just kind
of an issue of their own alternatives
such as Vimeo but they tend not to be as
effective as YouTube so is there a
free-market way to address such an issue
yeah I mean I think if things get bad
enough on YouTube then alternatives will
arise I think that the people with money
right now trying to think of ways to to
fix it I think I think as long as human
beings want more negative news than
positive news they'll be provided with
more negative news to positive views the
market is not they to fix our cognition
and to fix our desires it's something to
fix in that sense now we can advocate
for fixing if we change this audience
and the audience wants really good news
the media will provide that so you can't
expect the marketplace to fix social
problems although I think it does you
know I think discrimination is stuff
like that can be fixed by the market but
ultimately it has to be an intellectual
force so the fact that I'm for free
markets doesn't mean I think free
markets everything right I still think
that they're gonna be people like us
advocating and speaking and arguing
about the issues because I think into I
think intellectuals shape the culture I
think they dominate the culture and you
know they function within a free market
but that is not you know I don't know
that John Locke would have been the best
paid public speaker in the world yes he
was the most influential think of the
Enlightenment so it doesn't exactly call
I mean I think Iran was the most
important think of the 20th century
nobody would know nobody thinks that
except me so you know I mean I talk
about that I advocate for that you know
hopefully over time I'll build a market
for that but it takes time no you
these things take time
[Applause]
when things are that big there's right
now there isn't a whole lot of
competitors for them and also a Papa
died in a lot of conservatives start
forward counting these wouldn't it just
create more of a bubble where
conservatives are in their own bubble
and liberals they're in their own bubble
and then we never get to talk we never
get to talk to each other years over
media yeah we don't get to have a
discussion anymore and then on top of
that you know I don't exactly know where
you go and something is bigger so I mean
there's a couple things there first I
think you're right that if and you see
this sometimes and the new conservative
free speech site you know or social
media thing yes there's a risk there all
the conservatives leave and then Twitter
remains and it's all lefties there's a
problem there what I would say and
you're on just salute is this there are
get into all the specifics but there are
major discussions happening with big
time money people in Silicon Valley
right now trying to solve this problem
so if you feel that you don't want
Facebook to have all your information or
you don't or you think Twitter shadow
banning people or you're not happy with
YouTube videos not going out to feed
then use those sites or don't use those
sites but in the meantime we're just in
complete agreement that the market is
what has to solve it and it's just going
to be a little messy so that the things
that you're worried about probably will
kind of happen but eventually I think
it'll it'll present itself I'll just say
this quickly life did exist before
Facebook there was myspace it just shows
the difference in age there's an era
even before myspace maybe was Friendster
yeah friends wow you guys got French to
reference Wow all right that was pretty
good
okay
I'm the chapter leader of citizens find
the lobby here in Orlando and I've heard
both of you speak about climate change I
have a question about that well-defined
property rights are the foundation of
market forces and the market allocated
efficiently a big market Porter's what
about one property where property rights
are not well defined like in the
atmosphere which were allowed to use
like a free time how could the market or
what should the government do to make
the market I'll just give a one-liner
around this I just did a show that we
shot last week it'll be up next week
about some conservative solutions to
environment so definitely check that out
but I'll let you answer it I mean I
would say that nothing the government
should do nothing about it and if it's
real problem then again education is
important let's let's educate people
about that people will change their
behavior if they really think there's a
danger and they really think there's a
threat I think the problem with the
climate change debate is primarily the
solution being offered the solution
being offered don't use carbon fuels is
a non solution it's a non-starter it's
stupid it means death and destruction
you know if there really is a problem
and again I you usually take a neutral
stand I'm not a scientist I don't want
to get into that debate if there really
is an issue let's be creative about
finding solutions to it suck co2 out of
the atmosphere
you know spray something into the
atmosphere that dissolves the student I
don't know I'm right but it can't be
what I know because because I'm alive
you cannot ban fossil fuels that is a
that is a that is an anti-life answer
and as long as that's the answer the the
environmentalists present then forget
about it they you know they can win but
their winning means the destruction of
civilization as we know yeah we got a we
got a thank you though Thanks
so my question is for your on Brooks I
know you're a former idea and and you
also have been to Israel I notice that
nothing carries
it's not it's very common over there and
even the fact that that guns are not
prohibited in schools in Israel and you
don't really I don't hear any news of
mass shootings mass school shootings in
Israel and so I want to know what your
perspective is on that morning every
teacher but those teachers that are
experienced I mean
people carry openly in Israel if they're
really really well trained so you don't
Israel is not does not have liberal gun
laws for just everybody if you you know
but then everybody goes through the army
but even going to the army doesn't
guarantee that you're well trained those
people are really well trained are the
ones who you see open carry and of
course it is where you see security
guards everywhere because the security
guards everywhere
look I think the school shooting debate
were having the wrong debate I don't
think school shooting is about guns
school shooting is about why young young
kids in this country between the ages of
14 and 17 why so many of them are so
angry a Sony allistic are so hateful
that they would go into school and want
to hurt their fellow students not into
the mall not to a stadium summit but
into a school now this semi suggests
something wrong with our schools so I
think we need a debate in this country
about education policy about what
government schools are doing to our kids
why there's so much kneel ISM and
partially I think this relates the
antifa and relates to the violence
that's out there there is a real
Neolithic street Jordan Peterson talks
about this a lot in our young people in
your generation why I think it's because
of the educational system I think it's
close of government schools and I think
our government schools a training young
me Lister causing people to become
nihilistic that's
problem that's what needs to be dealt
with that's what needs to be challenged
and yes short-term if you want to put a
security guard there if you want to arm
a teacher if they're well trained if
they know how to use sure I don't have
any problem with that right but I don't
think that's a long-term solution the
long-term and and the thing nobody wants
to talk about why are these kids so
angry at their school I mean think about
the mentality of wanting to kill
everybody not a bully I can understand a
kid being bullied and taking a gun I
want you to shoot the bully know
everybody and you know the Columbine
kids wanted to blow up the school and to
kill 2,000 people they had bombs they
didn't work luckily right the bombs
didn't work and it's not about guns
right if they don't have guns all their
bombs so it's about education and I what
I want to have is a real discussion
about progressive education about
government schools about where the
school should be privatized about all of
that that to me is a thousand times more
important and issue than guns guns is
not an important in one way or the other
in my view now I know a lot of people
disagree with me on this but one way or
the other
I don't think guns matter if they took
if they took all our guns it doesn't
matter and if we kept all the guns it
doesn't matter that much what matters a
thousand times more is what's happening
in our schools just make it know so let
me cut let me cut you off cuz we're
gonna make this short right I advocate
for complete privatization of health
care a hundred percent but let me let me
add this I don't care how much money is
spent on health care like I have spent a
lot of money on unlike MRIs and cat
scans just to make sure I wasn't gonna
die now in the column of wasted money
that counts as wasted because they
didn't find anything cool I mean I view
that as a positive but if you're if you
if you look at aggregate numbers then we
spent a huge amount of money yes cuz we
spend a huge now what is the right
number to spend on health care who gets
the side the reason I wanted privatized
the reason I want to privatize it so you
can decide so I don't decide for you so
we as a group don't vote to decide how
much to spend on his healthcare I want
every individual to decide how much is
appropriate some people spend a huge
amount they'll get MRI every year
they'll check in some people say I don't
want to spend that much I'm gonna spend
less and if you had real free healthcare
free-market healthcare you'd have
variety of different insurance policies
and options so this is sort of what we
addressed earlier about if you give
something are they just gonna mean I
just think that we should have a
discussion about it I'm not even
concerned about legislation look they
used to be a semi automatic there it
used to be a ban on certain guns and it
went away so you actually won one battle
in that discussion right it went away I
don't know I'm not admitting I don't
know what the answer is exactly but you
know the idea that you should be able to
own a tank D legitimizes your right to
own a fight on and the idea that we
should nobody should have any guns G
legitimizes their position the position
is somewhere in between yeah I know you
do but that somebody is actually been in
one shot one blown stuff up with one I
don't
do you think that should be handled by
the federal government some people say
that when it was States or a better
result sort of we could quickly do it
for me it would be about going to the
states and as local and local and local
and local as possible in with as much
choice as possible I believe government
is essentially coercion and govern is
essentially a gun and I don't believe
guns belong in schools and therefore I
don't believe government has any any
role in education now I would be willing
to concede the in in a transition period
and it could be a long transition period
government funds education but
government should never run a school
whenever government runs a school it is
corrupting so I like education saving
account which Arizona's experimented
with and Nevada is experimenting with
where the government funds but you get
to choose what form of education your
kid gets and where it's given whether
it's on the internet or in a private
school but it should be 100% privatized
[Applause]
oh man she's tough we would state yeah
stick around
we'll take some selfies for me I would
say no actually the the Prager you video
that I did is literally their most
watched video ever Dennis and I have a
couple disagreements about politics but
he's running basically a conservative
website and and not only of the most
watched one but I just shot another one
a couple weeks ago that I think will be
out next week or a week after that so I
think and I'm pretty sure you would
agree with me that for the disagreements
we may have with these guys that there
is an absolute willingness to talk it
out and agree to disagree and also agree
to I'm friends with a lot of these guys
you know I mean I mean Ben Shapiro is
not thrilled with gay marriage but you
know I've had dinner with he and his
wife with my partner I mean it's fine
and I think that that's a more
overriding thing so I've seen some some
movement on the on the conservative side
intellectually that I'm happy to keep
talking to them about
so so my experience is a little
different and it depends on who we're
talking about so suddenly some people in
the religious right and I and I do think
Prager belongs they are intolerant of
certain views and it suddenly Prague is
so far at least being intolerant of
anything to do with Iran and it's been
pretty explicit from his perspective and
I think that's true of a number quite a
few people on on the right so I'm I'm
less positive generally about the right
then then Davis but because I've seen
that intolerance at least towards me and
my you know people who agree with me and
I also worry and this is again part of
my perspective of the right I worry that
the white gets associated with religion
right
and and to me you know I'm an atheist
and I think it's and I don't think
atheism is irrelevant to the discussion
I think it's I'm like I'm Lawrence am
Havas's site on this issue I think
atheism this question of religion is an
important question I think it needs to
be resolved I ultimately I think the
Western civilization to to exist we need
to have that conversation and I think we
will win so I think I think I worry
about the dominance of religion and the
Republican Party I worry about the
dominance of religion on on the
so-called right and I do see some
intolerance on that side too not just to
the atheism but the the the the kind of
atheism that I bring I think we know
maybe a more strident perspective on
these kind of issues and you know and
and and I take the abortion serious
issue seriously and I probably disagree
with many of you an abortion and I'm
with Dave on abortion and and and and
there's a number of these other issues
that I think we really do clash and
there really is an issue ben shapiro
seems to be an exception to that he's
really open to discussion and debating
and having a conversation about it but
we'll see where all of this goes i think
this is fascinating what dave has
managed to do and and i really give
credit to dave via is he really has
through his interviews and through the
network that he's created he's created
kind of an i'm in a sense an umbrella
people who are interested in debating
serious ideas and having real
conversations about deep issues and it's
the Dave's credit that this is all
coming because I don't think it would
have happened by itself somebody has to
be kind of the the facilitator and you
know Dave's saying to something you know
these Ironman guys are not that bad and
you know and and and you know hey ben
shapiro is a nice guy and and all of
this i think somebody has to be the
mediator but having that conversation i
think it's so crucial to you know
progress towards more freedom and more
liberty and more conversation and more
free speech so so i I celebrate what
dave has done even if I disagree with
with a lot of the people they on a lot
of the issues I think having that
conversation is so crucial and for you
right to be exposed to these
conversations I mean for the last 20
years there's been no television worth
watching of any intellectual content you
now have the best interview of his
generation actually creating great
intellectual content I mean it's amazing
actually I'm a little young for a
Lifetime Achievement Award but but you
guys are an incredible pimps above
everything that you're on just said so I
thank you guys for coming out of
defending free speech and open inquiry
and critical thinking and all that good
stuff we have a dinner to go to right
after this but we'll hang out and say hi
to a couple of you guys and I'm sorry we
didn't get to all the questions and now
make some noise for the people at home
so do they know
[Applause]
you